estamos en el mauri house en la haya y
estamos viendo probablemente la pintura
más famosa o tal vez no la más famosa
más bien una de las más conocidas en
general me refiero a la joven de la
perla' de fermín y es que esta pintura
parece haber ascendido en el gusto de la
gente a finales del siglo 20 y es que es
muy interesante pensar cómo la sociedad
escoge cierta pintura para llegar a la
fama así la gente se enamora de ella tal
vez sea porque fue una pieza central de
una película y también fue el tema
central de una novela o tal vez sea
porque sabemos tampoco acerca de la
pintura y también es muy interesante que
a esta obra se le conozca como la
monalisa holandesa pues en ambos casos
tenemos retratos del busto de una mujer
cuyos fondos son lugares indeterminados
ahora hay que ser cuidadosos porque esta
pintura puede parecer un retrato para
nosotros pero en efecto no es un retrato
la monalisa sí lo es y durante mucho
tiempo tuvo una identidad desconocida y
ahora estamos convencidos de quién
fue la monalisa pero en este caso este
no es un retrato esta pintura es lo que
se conoce como un trono que es una
representación de un personaje de un
peculiar tipo de persona un ejemplo es
la forma en la que tenemos algunas
situaciones en las comedias actuales
norteamericanas tenemos al héroe tenemos
al villano tenemos un cierto tipo de
persona y nosotros pensamos que ella es
un personaje exótico por su turbante sus
ropas se perciben foráneas y también por
suerte de verla de gran tamaño y la
forma en la que la vemos de lado pero
ella voltea hacia nosotros y esto nos da
algo momentáneo algo seductor que hace
que no le abordemos directamente y justo
esto es lo que se asemeja la monalisa en
ambos casos tenemos miradas que parecen
enigmáticas que estarán pensando quiénes
son cuál es nuestra relación con ella
ambas pinturas nos abren a varios tipos
de interpretación sin ninguna respuesta
correcta bueno hasta que alguien produce
una novela entera basada en este cuadro
del cual sabemos tampoco pero lo que sí
sabemos
la pintura es que su técnica es
realmente extraordinaria la sutileza de
la luz es impresionante en la manera en
que se refleja en la perla y está
contrasta con su cuello obscuro también
podemos observar la delicadeza de sus
características así como la armonía de
aquellos azules y oro ahora nosotros
sabemos que fermín trabajaba muy
despacio algunos historiadores del arte
han sugerido que sólo producía de 2 a 3
pinturas al año y es por eso que su
técnica es verdaderamente esperada y
podemos ver este cuidado en la forma en
la que crea a partir de la luz pero es
tan momentáneo aparecido cuando
observamos este paisaje holandés y
tenemos la sensación de que pasa el
tiempo y de que las nubes se mueven a
través del paisaje aquí tenemos la misma
sensación en una figura que solamente
gira su cabeza y parece que hablará con
nosotros o que nos abordará pero no
sabemos sobre qué y nuestros ojos están
en el proceso de enfocar la y ella ya
conoce nuestra mirada somos cómplices en
ese momento y esto me hace pensar
del color y en la sutileza de la luz y
en la intimidad que tenemos todo esto
nos hace registrar este momento tan
personal y quizás es por esto que esta
pintura sea tan querida